when I spoke to several teams making
games in the Left for Dead lineage they
each had some unique thoughts on why the
game and its resulting genre Works they
also each echoed one similar thought
pacing Reigns Supreme horde Shooters
like Warhammer 40K dark tide can live or
die on the flow of its Co-op missions
aided by an AI director missions must be
tuned to reliably challenge but not
necessarily overwhelmed the player
impressively dark tide gets this aspect
of its Grim Dark missions exactly right
the ways in which the game adds new
layers don't work quite as well
dark tide is not just a left for dead
like it's also the spiritual successor
to Fat shark's previous Series in the
genre vermintide moving the experience
out of the base Warhammer world and into
the far-flung and Grim dark future of
Warhammer 40K comes with a major
makeover both cosmetically and
mechanically the biggest new addition
comes in the form of an arsenal of
firearms then have no place in the hard
fantasy of traditional Warhammer but in
the 40K era things like hand cannons
assault rifles and electricity infused
projectiles not only fit right in but
also dramatically alter the flow of
combat by adding more range-based
considerations the massive shift is well
implemented as enemies will match you
blow for blow fighting from a distance
will see them trading shots and taking
cover and if you or they are able to
close the gap app they'll quickly swap
to melee combat when this happens dark
tide leans into the still great crowd
control elements first seen in
vermintide where both nuanced sword
fighting and Mindless hacking and
slashing are usually viable techniques
though on higher difficulties the former
naturally becomes more crucial for the
freshest experience for those coming
over from vermintide the veteran class
is the best as their most Adept with
guns and thus feel the most different
from The Archers and ax throwers of fat
shark's predecessor series no class is
without melee abilities thankfully as
the blend of ranged and melee combat is
key to what makes the game's combat Loop
works so well
dark tide doesn't shy from tropes of the
genre that have worked before such as
mini boss enemies that often fit
familiar archetypes this includes a
beast that pounces on you and
immobilizes you or another big brute
that charges after you and slams you
into the ground because of the
gunslinging some more novel mini bosses
show up too in each case be its novel or
cliche they work because their arrivals
in The Fray are well timed and adhere to
the game's exemplary pacing also
demonstrated in the steady stream of
common enemies which pour in by the
dozens at a time I don't think it's a
bad thing that players who are well
versed in the genre will recognize some
of these enemy archetypes mechanically
their ability to pin players or
dismantle team cohesion is critical so
it feels like there are only so many
directions in which to take mini bosses
when designing a game like this where
dark tide adds its own depth is in the
meta game of leveling up your created
character or characters not only do you
give give them a lengthy backstory which
helps contextualize the history for you
but it also colors how the squad mates
talk to each other eliciting banter
among the strange bedfellows
[Music]
that's a fun detail that may not even be
picked up by some players but no one
could Overlook the loot system which
adds layers not typically seen in games
like this completing missions and
challenges will earn you currency and
materials and with them you can buy new
weapons even dramatically altering your
character builds by switching to new
weapon classes when paired with Creator
teammates the game's tactical elements
really shine this works well even if
your group features some class overlap
but works best when one of each
character class is represented as you'll
have the full range of strengths
Available to You masking weaknesses
nearly to the point of non-existence but
no matter the roster the game really
relies on such cohesive squads as just
jumping into a game with randomized
teammates makes anything above normal
difficulty a struggle damage taken
skyrockets so it becomes a situation
where you almost have to operate like a
well-oiled machine or else you won't get
far thus as is often the case with games
like this it can be satisfying with
friends and frustrating with strangers
this issue is exacerbated by the Lesser
rewards you unlock on Lower difficulties
without a reliable team you may find it
best to play on normal or easy but the
currency and other rewards you'll get
for completing missions on those
difficulties are not generous enough and
drag the unlock and upgrade system way
down at least when I've had enough money
or supplies to improve my character's
inventory the changes have been evident
Doling out that reliable sense of
progress and Improvement that video
games are built on the free earned
in-game cosmetic pricing is more
noticeably out of order for roughly the
cost of two or three weapons that are
better than those with which will start
the game you can buy for example an
alternate colorway for your pants this
creates a two-part issue where the
prices are too steep and the rewards are
not so desirable there are other
Cosmetics too but so far they're mostly
lackluster the best stuff on offer is in
the Real Money Shop and in there prices
are roughly what you might be used to
full head to toe outfits will cost you
eight to twelve dollars however those
prices are usually seen in free-to-play
games whereas dark tide is a forty
dollar game that currently has too few
interesting Cosmetics available for free
the game has intentions of a live
service game and in its defense many
live service games open with too few
enticing Cosmetics but the pricing for
what's there compounds the issue
speaking of Cosmetics the game's look as
a whole is unappealing though I admit
your mileage may vary as this feeling
stems from my personal disinterest in
its source material Warhammer 40K is an
ugly world speaking both morally and
aesthetically fat shark manages to give
levels a general sense of scale and
atmosphere that I expect is faithful to
the IP but the combination of ubiquitous
rusted steel and vaguely charged like
venues albeit a neat metal music video
style juxtaposition enhanced by great
original music
fails to separate any one Mission from
another thus they all quickly blend
together missions are selected on an
Overworld map within a shared Social Hub
are our Destiny or you can jump into
Quick Play according to your difficulty
settings and several times when I was
thrown into a mission it took me a
surprising amount of time to realize
that I'd already played a particular
level before outside of major set pieces
none of them do well to stand out this
also affects the story as you'll likely
play it out of order giving how
matchmaking seems indifferent to your
story progress but you can override this
by choosing specific missions with
possibly longer queue times as a result
the story feels like little more than
background lore even as the game likes
to throw you into cutscenes at times for
players bringing Warhammer fandom into
the experience I'll bet they'll get more
out of it but for others it's going to
feel out of context and skippable
strap with Darkness I find dark tide
feels like both the natural progression
of vermintide's best parts as well as an
example of some growing pains in the
live service World things like combat
pacing and team builds are expertly
considered and crafted but metagame
elements such as chasing Loot and
cosmetics have some issues that are
admittedly common when a team tries to
create a new game with a long tail it's
both a promising left for deadlike and a
flawed live service but its issues are
fixable and the growth of vermintide
suggests that dark tide will also enjoy
a long shelf life as one of the better
games of its kind
foreign